this is considered the most right-wing
government in Israel's history led by
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu this
is the national security minister he was
once convicted of incitement to racism
and belonging to a terrorist
organization and this is the Finance
Minister he's advocated for permanent
Israeli rule over the West Bank without
giving Palestinians the right to vote
many of these politicians are strongly
in favor of the judicial overhaul plan
that sparked massive protests and
created a rift with allies it cannot
continue down this road while Netanyahu
now says he wants to see compromise he
needs to keep the support of his
Coalition in order to stay in power so
here's how Netanyahu came to be
politically reliant on religious and
Ultra nationalist parties and why the
interests of his government are now
clashing with many of Israel's citizens
and allies
before we talk about the judicial
overhaul let's talk about how Netanyahu
came back into power in the first place
just a few years ago it looked like his
political career might be over in 2019
he was indicted on bribery and fraud
charges which he denies and in 2021 his
Rivals agreed to form a new government
to oust him but Netanyahu didn't back
down
he fought the charges and even though he
was still on trial during the campaign
he pulled off an election Victory by
uniting right-wing ultra-nationalists
and religiously conservative parties
that opened the door for people like
itamar bengavir leader of the Jewish
power party to secure top government
positions
politicians in netanyahu's government
support all kinds of divisive policies
but one of their biggest priorities is
to overhaul the country's judicial
system so that they as politicians can
override Supreme Court decisions that
they don't agree with so why is this
judicial overhaul such a big deal to
them unlike in the U.S and some other
Western countries Israel doesn't have a
written Constitution judges are picked
by a Judicial selection committee not
politicians and they base their
decisions on British common law evolving
Israeli precedent and a series of basic
laws supporters of this system say it
provides checks and balances against
Parliament but for decades Israel's
right wing has accused the court of
having a left-wing bias for example most
Israelis are subject to mandatory
military service but many in netanyahu's
government want ultra-orthodox Jews to
be exempt from it so that they can study
Jewish texts full-time but when
parliament passed a law on that a few
years ago the court Struck it down
saying it was unconstitutional so fast
forward to January when Netanyahu and
his allies took power they put out
proposals to completely change the
system like giving lawmakers power on
the committee that appoints judges
making it easier for Parliament to
overrule Supreme Court decisions and
making it harder for judges to strike
down parliament's laws the proposals set
off a wave of protests with
demonstrators saying the overhaul would
weaken Israel's checks and balances this
is emergency time for the Democracy of
Israel
crucially scores of Israeli reservists
said they would refuse to serve if the
reforms passed on the other side
supporters of the proposals also
demonstrated demanding that the
proposals move forward
and they were cheered on by some in
netanyahu's cabinet who tweeted videos
and thanked them for their support with
flights grounded schools shut and banks
closed Netanyahu pressed Paws and his
Coalition agreed to suspend some of the
more contentious issues until after
Passover
but The Showdown is far from over
foreign
Coalition are still vowing to press
ahead with the reforms at the same time
Netanyahu is facing pressure from
Israeli citizens who continue to
demonstrate and the United States which
is Israel's largest security partner
like many strong supporters Israel I'm
very concerned Netanyahu responded
saying Israel is a sovereign country
which makes its Decisions by the will of
its people and not based on pressures
from abroad including from the best of
friends now analysts say if Netanyahu
really wants to reach a consensus he'll
have to give members of his Coalition
something in return already he has
agreed to give Ben gevir the national
security minister even more power by
handing him control of the National
Guard a move that would put the
ultra-nationalist in charge of handling
protests
thank you